right okay the most amazing delicious
start okay it's easy to do tastes
delicious and it's so so simple it's our
Bettis Catalan get it done look I just
did already
now please it may be a starter tonight
but they just make the most amazing
quick easy supper dish as well so you
really want to learn this stay with me
Catalan get hold of your Chile here we
go well done Haley rub it to go okay
okay
you'd be bouncing noise cook well it's a
bit bigger than that we're longing
startegy means bouquet right from there
yeah yeah okay I got the end okay
oh good now try there's little seeds in
there that's what we want good girl see
now the idea is getting the seeds
doesn't make passing too hot good girl
no from there I'm gonna chop it very
fine
this is what I want to learn chopping
quick right here we go just walk the
knife just up and down that's it let the
knife do the work good girl now watch
your fingers oh it's not being on the
generation okay now look from there look
let me show you again look here we go
nice and fine
good that's better rock that's not good
Gordon drop the knife here let me shake
that's better
Rock the knife good now remember nails
Lisa okay now Chili's are done okay get
Springer's together okay bring onion no
that's yeah i'll bunch them together
bunch and again okay no don't look at
diamond here just rock nice
oh and they'll be creaming their pants
[Applause]
words Linda I never I've been told your
wife's name
okay tonight Oh